es ist so gut wie sicher astronauten
werden andere planeten besuchen und
höchst wahrscheinlich werden wir den
weltraum auch demnächst zu einem
dauerhaften außenposten der menschheit
machen doch wer wird das tun spielen
nasa esa und andere staatliche
weltraumagenturen dann noch eine rolle
oder wird es wie im internet private
unternehmen übernehmen im wahrsten sinne
des wortes die macht klicks und science
fiction
die gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nicht herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für diesen themen vorschlag
bei whatsapp in der video beschreibung
da findet er den link zu unserem
newsletter gucken wir einmal kurz zurück
in die geschichte der raumfahrt in ihren
anfängen waren es vor allem die usa und
die sowjetunion die wirklich wahnsinn
traumfahrt mission in die tat umgesetzt
haben zwischen 1950 und 1970 schickte
man die menschen ins all und auf dem
mond dabei waren kurz vorher erst
raketen erfunden worden doch damals ging
es ausschließlich darum raketen als
trägersysteme für sprengstoffe
atomwaffen einzusetzen die visionen von
bemannten raumflügen waren damals nicht
geplant erst 100 55 ging dazu der
wettlauf los sputnik wurde ins all
geschickt dann kam die hündin laika und
dann juri gagarin dann die landung auf
dem mond 1969 der absolute hammer
und das bis heute seitdem gibt es
bemannte raumfahrt nur noch im erdnahen
weltraum rückblickend gesehen war das
goldene zeitalter der raumfahrt
ausschließlich politisch motiviert kaum
war der wettlauf gewonnen war auch schon
vorbei doch auch diese zeiten sind
vorbei und den weltraum unser
sonnensystem werden kontinuierlich
erforscht doch fest steht auch die
staatlichen raumfahrt organisationen
können nicht mehr unsummen einfach so
raus hauen kein staat dieser welt würde
sich wohl heutzutage so etwas leisten
wie das apollo-programm milliarden teuer
dafür vielleicht aber eine privatperson
und hier sind wir schon mitten im
vergleich private raumfahrt
organisationen wie spacex sind nicht an
politische vorgaben gebunden eine
riesige chance sie können ihre raketen
ins all schicken wie und wann sie wollen
und damit sogar geld verdienen in
zukunft ein riesiges geschäftsfeld oft
wird das mit der entwicklung der
computer verglichen damals nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg waren es riesige
unhandliche maschinen
die in großen gebäuden untergebracht
wurden und kein normaler mensch konnte
etwas damit anfangen
nur staatliche unternehmen konnten sich
diese maschinen leisten bis dann private
firmen in den markt eingestiegen sind
die computer wurden dadurch nicht nur
preiswerter sondern auch kleiner und
flexibler mehr leute kauften sie auch
für den privaten gebrauch und so wurden
die computer noch billiger mittlerweile
sind sie überall auch in unseren autos
telefonen und fernsehgeräten und genauso
entwickelt sich die raumfahrtindustrie
gerade sie wird eine von
privatunternehmen geführte industrie
gerade haben
richard branson die ticketpreise für
einen flug in den erdorbit und allen
masc für flüge zum mars bekannt gegeben
eine riesen chance denn dadurch werden
raumflüge nicht nur billiger sondern
auch einfacher und sicherer werden nicht
nur astronauten und astronautinnen
sondern normale menschen wie du und ich
werden vielleicht schon bald ins all
fliegen in zukunft vielleicht sogar so
routiniert und unaufgeregt wie viele von
uns ins flugzeug steigen um sommerurlaub
zu machen die private raumfahrt kann so
also entwicklung voran tragen die die
staatliche raumfahrt sony hätte umsetzen
können
auf der anderen seite hat die staatliche
raumfahrt ja auch ihre vorteile hier
geht es eben nicht mehr darum erst dann
zu sein
das hat jetzt die private raumfahrt
übernommen stattdessen hat die
staatliche raumfahrt sich auf solide
grundlagen forschung konzentriert durch
die wir den weltraum immer besser
verstehen können dennoch fehlt es leider
eben an der motivation eine spektakuläre
und langfristige mission wie
beispielsweise einen flug auf den mond
oder mars anzugehen das liegt wie eben
aber auch schon erwähnt an finanziellen
und politischen erwägungen doch so
stellen die privaten betreiber wie
spacex den raumfahrtagenturen die
existenzfrage
denn sie sind ihren geldgebern den
bürgern rechenschaft schuldig das hat
mit vor kurzem funktioniert denn da gab
es einfach keine alternative zu den
staatlichen anbietern
doch nasa esa und so weiter dürfen nicht
vergessen dass sie einen gewissen
anspruch gerecht werden müssen
sie haben die aufgabe den fortschritt
der gesellschaft zu sichern und moderne
technik zu entwickeln einen schritt in
die richtige richtung hat vielleicht das
großherzogtum
luxemburg gemerkt 2018 gemacht luxemburg
what s hat eine eigene weltraum agentur
gegründet das ziel der luxemburg space
agency nsa private unternehmen beim
weltraum forschungsprojekten zu
unterstützen und zwar mit staatlichen
mitteln damit will das großherzogtum
eine führende rolle bei der
wirtschaftlichen nutzung des weltraums
erlangen große pläne haben in sachen
asteroiden bergbau hier will man
beispielsweise rohstoffe wie wasser und
sauerstoff im all gewinnen und für die
weltraumindustrie verfügbar machen
der rechtliche rahmen für dieses
vorhaben ist in luxemburg als einziges
land in europa bereits geschaffen schon
2017 hatte man ein gesetz erlassen das
den abbau von rohstoffen für asteoriden
ermöglicht auch wenn das gesetz äußerst
umstritten ist hatten sich daraufhin
viele firmen der weltraum branche mit
ihren zentralen nach luxemburg begeben
die nsa wird jedenfalls eng mit der esa
zusammen arbeiten erste konkrete
aktionen im weltall sind jedoch zeitnah
noch nicht geplant anders bei allen masc
er steckt milliarden in seine firma
spacex profitiert von der staatlichen
forschung und alles andere kann ihm egal
sein wenn der menschen zum mars schicken
will kann er das ganz alleine
entscheiden und auch umsetzen auf der
anderen seite kann man das natürlich
auch wieder kritisch sehen denn anders
als staatliche organisationen muss er
sich in seinem ganzen tun nicht der
öffentlichkeit gegenüber rechtfertigen
denn er hat schließlich keine
verantwortung uns gegenüber wie und
wofür er sein geld ausgibt all das hängt
an ihm eine milliardär genauso wie auch
bei jeff paterson richard branson die
ähnliche visionen haben theoretisch
können sie aber auch von heute auf
morgen wieder auf der spielfläche
verschwinden das ist bei große
organisation wie der nasa oder der esa
nicht wirklich vorstellbar und
andererseits wenn sie die
raumfahrtindustrie durch niedrige preise
dominieren haben sie plötzlich die macht
im weltraum
ob sie wäre es da nicht viel
verantwortungsvoller wenn der weltraum
nicht einzelnen milliarden bzw
ihren firmen gehört sondern der ganzen
gesellschaft ja aber diese überlegung
ist jetzt schon hinfällig denn fest
steht der raumfahrt stehen wilde zeiten
bevor und das haben wir vor allem spacex
und allen anderen firmen zu verdanken
die den weltraum erobern die
fundamentale bedeutung der raumfahrt für
dieses spannende video hier
klicken und unbedingt den kanal neugier
zone auch abonnieren ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran